let's talk about strikes then shall we
because once again we're suffering from
them here in London on the Underground
and bus services we've got rail strikes
across the country again tomorrow why
has this not been resolved
I think essentially now because the
union bosses won't put the settlement
deals to their members so we've had a
situation where uh eight percent over
two years has been offered it's
different depending on which piece of
the rail we're talking about here but
broadly speaking and uh the bosses for
example the boss of the rmt uh simply
make the decision without going out to
their membership to ask them whether
they would like to uh settle this and
and get back to work where it has gone
to the members that was in a smaller
Union called the tssa the members
overwhelmingly voted for that deal uh
over 70 so it's quite clear that the
union bosses are trying to prevent the
workers from actually being put the
offer have the offer put in front of
them
well yeah you say it's all down to the
union bosses and you've really come out
fighting on this haven't you as far as
the unions are concerned uh you
published a 16-point plan as well about
taking on the unions but don't most
people just want a resolution they want
to see you talking to the to the unions
yourself they want a more conciliatory
tone have you got this wrong
yeah so the it's the employers and the
unions to discuss this obviously because
they're the only two who can settle it
um and indeed they've been in discussion
and I think what is a very reasonable
payoffer has been made remember the
average rail worker the medium is uh
forty four thousand pounds so that's the
average salary on a train driver and the
train drivers are also out on strike
with a separate Union uh their average
is nearly 60 000 pounds
um so we're you know I'm all in favor of
well paid uh rail workers uh who
received a huge amount of support from
your viewers the taxpayers during the
virus um during coronavirus to the tune
of 16 billion pounds or 600 pounds for
every household watching your program so
the public has supported the railway and
the railway workers it's time for the
union bosses to get out the way and put
the deals on the table to their members
so we can have this thing settled and
the point about my 16 point plan which
is really to a look at the union
legislation and see if it's in the right
place is really to hand that power back
to the to the rail workers uh or workers
across the whole economy actually not
just in rail rather than have it sit
with some of these union bosses who you
know in some cases including the rmt
boss say they hanker for the days of
Union Baron power from the 1970s we
don't need that kind of industrial
relations we just need to have this
thing settled
but we do need to have this thing
settled and the union bosses would say
that the offer that's on the table Falls
way below inflation and when a lot of
people sympathize with that there are a
lot of people around the country who are
facing inflation outstripping their own
wages and isn't it the case that a lot
of people will have sympathy with those
Railway workers when they're they're not
tempted to take an offer that's below
inflation
I think we're all concerned you know
everyone would have sympathy within the
inflation argument and you know let's
remember it's the supply chain
recovering after coronavirus it's Putin
Going To War uh in Ukraine that's caused
this Global uh inflation Spike um but
the offer on the table is pretty decent
for as I say the average train worker on
44 000 the average driver on sixty
thousand pounds a government's got to
sort of balance that with you know
nurses who are paid 31 000 or care
workers 21 000. you know I think it's
important that we balance that across
the economy I of course everyone would
love it for it to be more in fact one of
the good things for um the railways is
some of the reforms required some of the
modernizations are so out of date for
example paper time sheets being used
still on the maintenance side in some
cases maintenance teams not allowed to
be sent from for example Houston to
King's cross because the rmt claims
those that five minute walk puts them in
two different regions and you can't
therefore use the maintenance teams and
so many other examples means that there
are actually a lot of modernizations
that can help fund some of these pay
increases but as I say the big block is
that these union bosses refuse to allow
the offer on the table to be put to
their members it's one of the reasons in
my 16-point plan to tackle the unions
that I'm saying that in future it should
be the case that union members have to
put proper offers to their membership
rather than blocking them at uh at Union
Executives okay or reunion Baron level
so you're saying that the unions are
blocking progress that the mick Lynch of
the rmt says that you're the obstacle to
progress and he says the government's
bailing out companies to enable them to
continue working during strikes he's
also suggesting the government's backing
compulsory redundancy so are you
well the deal on the table
um actually for the rmt particularly on
the network rail side as I say it's
slightly complicated here because there
are several different negotiations in
play across the railway but the the deal
that's on the table actually means
largely no compulsory redundancies at
all uh again if you're not prepared to
put that deal to your membership we'll
never know whether the members would
accept it what I do know and I can say
for sure is if we can't get this settled
uh in the way that we're proposing which
is please put the deal to your
membership then we will have to move to
what's called a section 188 this is a
process of actually requiring these
changes to go into a place that becomes
mandated and that is the direction that
this is moving in now so these reforms
these modernizations some of which
update rules that go back to the 50s 60s
and 70s one which is the the inability
for us to run a service properly on a
Sunday without people volunteering so we
can't contractually put this in place
goes back 100 years over 100 years if we
can't get those modernizations in place
we will have to impose those
modernizations but we'd much rather do
it through these these offers actually
being put to their members
Steve White is the managing director of
Southeastern Railway he he's frustrated
he's tweeted actually saying does any
Railway colleague or customer really
want this to last for months it's time
for a ceasefire our people deserve a pay
rise and job security so he's calling
there for a pay rise he says our
Industries exist to serve our customers
and Community more talks are needed then
some more and then some more you should
be around the table shouldn't you
sorting this out now
well the people who have to be around
the table are the employers and uh the
workers representatives in this case the
the unions they're the only people who
can settle the strike uh of course
government sets the Mandate overall
because we have the further wider
responsibility for not just how much
real workers are paid but how much uh
care workers are paid how much staff in
the NHS doctors and nurses and police
and so many other public services so of
course we have to set an overall
framework the treasury has has done that
in a way as I say
um rail is fortunate there is so much
modernization required for work
practices which have no place in the
21st century uh at all I'll give you a
good example of this is
um there are the same number of ticket
office more or less than there were when
virtually all the tickets were sold at
ticket offices we wanted to get people
out from behind the glass and onto the
stations helping helping customers sorry
to interrupt you but you're saying this
has got nothing to do with the
government there's nothing you can do
there's nothing you can do to move this
on
and that's not what I'm saying I'm
saying uh the government has to set the
overall mandate the framework but the
technical discussions have to take place
between the employers and the unions and
they have been and that's why we've got
offers of eight percent over two years
on the table with uh as I say it varies
depending on which part of the the which
Union and which part of the Railway
we're talking about but no compulsory
redundancies for example with the
network rail maintenance side and much
more if the unions won't put the offer
to their members I'm afraid we will have
to impose some of these Solutions and
that's where we're moving to now okay
talking about Solutions labor has called
for the government to restore Avanti
West Coast Services after they've
announced a reduced service we've got um
Andy Burnham the mayor of Manchester
talking to us a little bit later on so
tell us what what you're doing about
this what what action are you going to
take
well it is it it's a bit pots kettle
black because
the problem of anti-west Coast which is
to do with
um the azleth Union uh calling
unofficial uh action and they're voted
for uh action shorter strikes so we know
that is the case has meant that they
were withdrawn uh voluntary day working
it actually exemplifies everything
that's wrong about the way that the
railway is being run but rather than
contractually running our Railway we
have volunteer days to do it and we had
a 90 drop uh three days after the union
voted to withdraw uh to do everything
short and striking so we know it must be
connected
um to that ballot which meant that vanti
West Coast could no longer run a
reliable service so when you have Andy
burning on I hope you're going to ask
him since he takes money from the unions
when he's gonna tell his friends in the
unions
um to get this sorted out and stop
playing games with people's lives the
only reason they're not running a
service is because of those unions and
they are demonstrating why the railways
so desperately need of Reform and as I
say we will bring in that reform my 16
point plan which I've no doubt the uh
the the new government the new
Administration will be adopting will in
fact bring this reform uh if the unions
aren't going to settle it any other way
is this really about strikes isn't this
about train companies just not having
the drivers that they need and he would
say to you no doubt are you going to
withdraw the franchise if they don't
come up with some solution to this
but the solution's been there all along
right so ordinarily enough drivers
though to cover their shifts we'll hold
on a second ordinarily and this is
because we have this extraordinary
situation on our Railways where what's
called rest day working or overtime is
what's used in many cases to run
services so to give you an example or
more than clearly here on on the west
coast quite a lot of the service has to
be filled by people simply volunteering
to work those days any normal contract
any normal contract would say uh that
you're contractually required to work on
certain days up to a certain number of
hours of course we don't have that on
large parts of our Railway which is
crazy and it's one of the things that
we're trying to change to modernize our
Railway it just because in 1919 Sundays
were protected
um as a rest day where no one ever
worked there's no longer fit with the
21st century where actually particularly
post-coronavirus more people are
traveling for leisure so more people are
attract on Sundays than any other day
and yet we're stuck with these contracts
which simply don't reflect the reality
of today so I hope when you're speaking
to any of the unions or any of the labor
party and Burnham included who take
money from these unions who are messing
up our Railway and messing with people's
lives stopping people from getting to
work during the week many of whom will
be the hardest people in Britain I hope
you'll be saying to them that rather
than be conflicted and talk speak up for
the unions they'll speak up for the
traveling public which is what we're
doing which is why we're requiring these
reforms which deserve support
okay as transport secretary also I want
to ask you about pno because uh as you
will know they announced sudden
redundancies back in March but its owner
has reported a bumper profit so what's
your reaction
well look as far as p o are concerned I
I I've been absolutely crystal clear I
think their boss the CEO needs to resign
he's still under investigation uh uh
which is uh absolutely right for the way
that he behaved and we've changed the
law uh with regard to
um some of the kind of detail of what
happened there and we brought forward a
nine point plan to make sure that no
Ferry company could do this again
including ensuring legislating to make
sure that they have to pay the minimum
wage when they are frequently in British
Waters so p o are going to have to
overturn what they've done here they
will have no choice in law very shortly
they should recognize that and make that
change now
you're backing Rishi sunak in the
conservative leadership race is it time
for him to hand in the towel he's more
than 30 points behind in the polls and
the government has urgent business it
needs to address with the cost of living
crisis we're told we have to wait for a
new prime minister for Action to be
taken
I mean we'll know who the new prime
minister is in a little over two weeks I
I don't think uh it would be right for
uh either side to not allow a formal
vote to to go ahead and if there's one
thing we've learned from the last few
years as uh you know I think of the 2015
election I was passing chairman at the
time everyone said we couldn't win the
uh the election I think it's 2016 brexit
uh poll where everyone was pretty sure
the country was about to vote for remain
I think it'd be a very good idea to wait
for those who are voting in this contest
to complete the vote so it's only just
over a fortnight's time and we know the
the answer to that
um and uh you know in the meantime many
of us are working very hard to to make
sure that
um you know services are available this
summer is what I've been doing I haven't
been away this summer I've been looking
after the transport system to make sure
that people can get away on holiday for
example